this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development good evening let me welcome
all of you here tonight I was just
commenting this is an engineering school
so we got to be able to fix the
microphone I would think um I'm uh Jim
plumber the dean of the engineering
school and we're delighted to have a
capacity crowd here in Nvidia Auditorium
and literally hundreds of others who are
watching this event this evening over a
live webcast and so we're welcome to all
of you we're here as all of you know
tonight to uh honor Professor Brad
Parkinson and to induct him into the
Stanford engineering uh heroes hall of
fame this is um a very very special
event for us uh there are currently um
12 14 actually people who have been
inducted into the engineering heroes
hall of fame and Brad is uh the most
recent of those this includes people
like uh Bill huet Dave Packard Fred
Turman Vince surf um and Craig bar who
was the CEO of Intel Corporation so it's
a very distinguished uh group these are
people collectively and individually who
have profoundly Advanced the course of
human social and economic progress uh
through engineering and they are all
Affiliated um often in many ways with
Stanford engineering we're tremendously
proud of all of them we're also
delighted tonight that um uh Brad's
family some of them at least are here
tonight I think his wife Jenny and his
daughter Leslie and his son Bruce are
here so welcome to all of you I've lost
track of where you are but there they
are right welcome and within the
audience there actually are a number of
other people I think uh who have made uh
significant contributions to GPS uh
throughout its U history and and
evolution and and more modern and more
recent work um I'm I don't want to start
naming names because I'll miss many of
you if I do that but one person I did
notice who who is here is Jim spieler
and so we'd like to welcome uh Jim who
made major contributions to GPS as
well so un unlike many uh um award
events uh the only thing that we ask of
people who are inducted into the
engineering Heroes uh group is that they
spend a day with us and we'll set up the
day in any way that they want and try
and make it a very special day for them
so when we talked to Brad about this he
said he'd like to spend some time with
students and so he and I had the great
uh pleasure of having uh dinner and
spending some time a little while ago
with a group of AO Astro graduate
students and undergraduate students and
it was a a fascinating discussion about
uh both what's going on now and what
happened uh during the year the
formative years of of GPS uh Brad also
suggested uh the topic of this talk
tonight which is a fascinating topic GPS
for Humanity I think we're all looking
forward to hearing what Brad will tell
us both about the past but also more
interesting perhaps about the future of
uh
GPS so as all of you know Brad is widely
known as the uh Chief Architect of the
GPS system um it's really thanks to his
work uh as a Air Force Colonel back in
1973 that today all of us take for
granted the fact that we can know where
we are in the world in X Y and Z
Dimensions to Great precision and this
this just seems so simple and so easy
today that we sometimes lose track of
the amount of work and energy and effort
that went into uh designing and and
implementing the system now many people
think of uh GPS as a just as a way to
get directions I mean there are more
than two billion GPS receivers in the
world today and a lot of us use them in
our vehicles and other ways to get
directions to the nearest Starbucks or
whever we might be wanting to go but I
think what you're going to hear tonight
is that uh there are actually are many
many other very interesting past present
and future applications of the GPS
system and I don't want to steal any of
Brad Sunder so I'll let him tell you
about some of the uh ideas he has about
the future uh in addition to his GPS
work of course Brad LED uh a group of
students and staff here in the AO Astro
department at Stanford uh on a whole
variety of application areas uh using
GPS system systems ranging from
automated plane landing systems to
self-driven tractors and so on and he'll
tell you a bit about those uh he also
was one of the leaders of the uh gravity
Pro B project uh which uh a satellite
that was launched some years ago that
validated to really an unprecedented
degree of accuracy Einstein's general
theory of of Relativity Brad also had a
very distinguished military career
received a bronze star two air medals uh
in the presidential unit Citation for
his service uh during the Vietnam
War Brad um in addition to his academic
um uh Enterprises uh actually had quite
a bit of experience in Industry as well
in fact he was CEO of Trimble for a time
period when he took a leave of absence
from Stanford to uh run uh that company
which obviously is deeply involved in
GPS systems he's he's he's received
essentially every possible award that
could be given to an engineer he's a
member of the National Academy and so on
but uh probably the biggest of these is
the Charles Stark Draper prize which is
sometimes called the Nobel Prize uh for
engineers so Brad is highly recognized
for the things that he's done he's a
member of the national inventers Hall of
Fame so tonight we're here to celebrate
um what he has done throughout his
career and to listen to a little bit
about his uh vision for the future of
the GPS system and before we let uh Brad
begin his talk Brad I wanted to give you
in thanks for being with us this is a
replica of the plaque which hangs on the
wall just outside the auditorium here
recognizing you as a Stanford
engineering hero so congratulations and
thank you for
[Applause]
being well good evening and it's uh a
real Delight to be here and see a lot of
faces that I have known in the recent
past the distant past and no currently I
was I was totally surprised and shocked
by this award frankly I did not expect
it at all so thank you Stanford thank
you Dean plumber School of Engineering
for this recognition and thanks to my
department I suspect that they had some
hand in that paringa and charville bar
hat before addressing my main subject uh
I'd like to reminisce a little bit about
Stanford and engineer
ing Robert Frost had a famous poem you
may
recall two roads diverged in a yellow
wood and sorry I could not travel both
and be one traveler long I stood well I
was such a traveler in
1964 I was a young Air Force Captain and
the Air Force was sponsoring me to go
back for a PhD in June this was uh like
in
March I wanted to Broad my graduate
experience and so I had uh deliberately
looked at something Beyond
MIT and I
had we got into that earlier didn't
we I'd already been accepted at the
University of Michigan for a program in
instrumentation and
control and in March of 1964 a strange
coincidence occurred another Captain
showed up fresh on his way from Stanford
to the Pentagon
and he'd been here as a graduate student
and he spoke enthusiastically about the
PHD program here Stanford hadn't even
been on my radar screen so I researched
it for about two days and I quickly
chose a new road I called the Air Force
Headquarters and I frantically told them
cancel Michigan and try to get me to
Stanford I'd never applied to
Stanford neither had the Air Force
applied for me but somehow there was a
miracle you know you know the equation
and suddenly there's a miracle there's a
miracle and the Air Force managed to
turn things around and about six weeks
later I showed up on the campus as an
aero Astro student indeed I have never
regretted switching to that other Road
and I didn't wait very long to do it I
still Revere the wonderful professors I
had here and the classes they were
outstanding many of my fellow students
became lifelong friends I think those
aspects are still
here they're still major strengths of
Stanford engineering I look back fondly
on my 28 years as a professor and I have
just a wonderful bunch of colleagues
perena Bob Cannon Dave Powell Dan de
Francis
Everett the indomitable Francis Everett
I should say John tenor Jim spilker and
I see Elizabeth Pat Cornell back there
so uh that was a wonderful aspect but
it's my PhD students that I have to
really acknowledge an enormous debt
they've been creative they've been
energetic their accomplishments in my
opinion are truly world class and I'd
like to thank them I saw a few of them
here today I'd like to thank them all
for that experience so thinking back to
the spring of
1964 two roads diverged in a wood and I
I took the One Less Traveled by and that
has made all the difference so with that
I'd like to launch off and talk a little
bit about GPS for
Humanity GPS has many applications for
worldwide benefit and uh some we
anticipated some are very surprising I'd
like to dedicate my
remarks to the many aerospace engineers
and supporters who labored and sacrific
to make this thing
happen sometimes we call it the stealth
utility
This Global Positioning and timing
service it's more than simply a
satellite system it's the service that
it renders and it's four-dimensional
so we occasionally think of position
it's just three dimensions fortunately
we always have some physicists around to
remind us there's one more but this is
truly a worldwide system and all four
dimensions are are important and you're
going to hear about those in just a
minute this is sort of an outline of my
talk
uh I'm going to talk about the initial
studies that were done rapidly tell you
about the GPS design meeting the key
Innovations and challenges we had but
most of the talk is going to focus on
applications for Humanity I'm going to
mention some surprises two of which were
triggered by Stanford and the
Innovations and I'm going to talk a
little bit about the future and the the
major threat that I see to
GPS John Kennedy said success has a
thousand fathers failur is an orphan I
don't know who started who said that the
first time but I'd like to acknowledge
there were a lot of parents of GPS and
I'd like to point out this person this
is Dr ion gettting he had the vision
back in 1960 there ought to be a better
system a better way to do it and he
envisioned a worldwide navigation system
and he sponsored a study the first GPS
type it wasn't called GPS then the first
GPS system study that was done in 1964
to
1966 and this is the front page from
that
study the interesting thing these two
gentlemen here Jim Woodford haroshi
Nakamura brilliant Space Engineers who
put this thing together the interesting
thing was it was secret I couldn't even
tell anyone about this study and it was
not made public until
1979 a year and a half after we launched
the the first GPS satellite and 6 years
after GPS had been
defined so in 1972 I was the Air Force
program director for a competing
predecessor to GPS and our first Air
Force proposal was rejected in August of
73 and I was then asked by a deputy
secretary of defense to try again in the
fall of
1973 I called a small meeting well away
from from Los
Angeles in the Pentagon and we held that
meeting over Labor Day weekend in 1973 I
call it the lonely and darkened Halls
because it is a fairly lonely place when
everyone's on
vacation my purpose was to select a
navigation system architecture that
combined the best knowledge we had at
that time perhaps the only light came
from the fifth floor up there and as I
recall we generated more than a little
Heat at the same time the only attendees
at that meeting were 10 Young Air Force
officers from my program office one
naval officer Commander Bill Houston
shown
here uh a few people from Aerospace
including Frank
Butterfield and these three officers
were absolutely key in what we did all
three are brilliant Gaylord green
happened to have a master's from Aro
Astro at Stanford so you see that there
is a recurring theme in my talk tonight
I'm certain that surprises you we
converged on a variation of the most
challenging of the Alternatives that had
been developed by Woodford and Nakamura
this chart I'm not going to go into uh
obviously it's more more complex than
you could possibly discuss but the point
is we picked the hardest one this lists
14 Alternatives and describes their
characteristics what we picked
assumed an atomic clock in space which
hadn't ever been done and a
simple uh simple clock in the user
equipment with the user actually
defining where he was by listening to
four satellites so it's the most
challenging alternative it gave four
dimensions if you will four satellites
in view it was passive with the
implication that you could have an
infinite number of
users and the user did all the calcul
in so with that as a background what did
the system really look like here was the
system in September of 1973 and it's
virtually identical to the GPS you know
today four satellit space hardened
atomic clocks four ranging
measurements and here comes a new piece
of
technology the passive ranging signals
and they were given a technical name
CDMA code division multiple
access allowed all of the satellite to
be broadcast on exactly the same
frequency you say what's the big deal
the big deal is that enabled our
accuracy and precision that occurred
later and the reason is all those
signals were locked together as soon as
you received them but had never been
done
before we had the user
equipment users obviously include
Aviation and
then importantly we had a control
segment on the ground that would watch
the satellites
predict where they were going to be 12
hours later up to 12 hours later and do
that with an accuracy of a few meters
after 990,000 miles of
travel so there were a lot of things
that were challenging about this but
perhaps the most challenging is the new
technology this is that unique signal
obviously ouble e would love this thing
because it's got lots of ones and zeros
there but what would happen is each
satellite had its own own code and by
regenerating the code in your receiver
you can wander around in the noise until
you find that signal and figure out
where it started and that defines time
so with four of those you were able to
actually navigate I should at this point
uh acknowledge Jim spilker who was a key
in the analysis and construction of what
that signal would look like but that
wasn't the only
challenge the
uh I I call this the five major
engineering challenges for GPS success
there were certainly demonstrating that
CDMA signal and getting all of its
characteristics for example this
prediction of where the satellite would
be had to come down to the user on a
teeny little pipe of 50 bits per second
data that is a real
challenge the second one space hardened
atomic clocks atomic clocks have been
around for probably 20 years
but no one had tried to put them up into
the upper Van Allen belt and have them
last for any length of time and that was
part of what we were trying to do I've
already mentioned the orbit prediction
problem this one sounds a little mundane
spacecraft lifetime it turns out if you
have a system such as GPS with that many
satellites if the satellites don't last
a long time you're going to buy a lot of
satellites and as a matter of fact the
Russians have tried to replicate what we
have they have a system called glonass
it turns out they have never never been
able to approach our lifetimes typical
lifetimes of their satellites are three
years we have many that are over 20 and
it makes the system
affordable last and perhaps as important
as anything else we had to come up with
a user equipment concept that could
eventually be made cheap in the
beginning it wasn't cheap it was
$250,000 for a receiver
not
cheap there was another aspect of the
program the Air Force really didn't like
this program they like to buy
airplanes and there were many attempts
to zero out the budget and stop the
program in its tracks so I was not only
directing a technical program I was also
fighting a running gun battle with
hostile forces in the
Pentagon and I could never have
succeeded in that and I mean this most
sincerely without
mentoring support within the Pentagon I
had GPS Mafia the GPS Godfather was this
man this man was the number three man in
the Department of Defense and for
reasons that I assume we're enlightened
he said GPS was his favorite program and
don't you forget it and I think he told
the Air Force listen if you cancel him
I'm canceling a wing of your airplanes
so as long as he was there we were guard
started his uh his strong support was
essential to Our
Success so the sequel we've had 53
successful launches basically into the
same configuration that we advocated in
the beginning initially we said three
planes and now if you count them up
there there's actually six nominally 24
satellites 11,000 Mi up three or four
continents away if you will and when
you're using GPS you're receiving
signals from satellites 11,000 miles
away it's not a big deal for the space
engineers but think about it they're a
long ways away I'm very proud of the
record we had we launched that first
satellite in 44 months and that was from
a dead start uh and it worked very very
well the uh block one satellite
continued on with 10 launches then nine
more 11 more all by
Rockwell the uh locked Martin company
came through with 12 and then nine more
and now we're in the middle of 2f we
have uh two launches already with 10
planned and we are with locked Martin
developing yet another uh satellite I if
you look at it there are 31 of the 53
launches that are still alive for a
program that started back in 1978 so in
terms of that challenge of Lifetime and
I don't take any credit I give lots of
credit to loed Martin and Boeing for
developing satellites that could do
something like that now there were a
couple of defining events that I'd like
to tell you about and remind you of uh
back uh in
1983 the Russians Soviets actually shot
down a
kal7 airliner which they stated had
flown over the camka peninsula I don't
know if you remember that they did that
in September 1st and within roughly two
weeks President Reagan declared clared
to the world that GPS would be available
free of
charge that was a big change and the
reason that was a big change civilians
had always used the signal they were
using it already but this established a
place that said if you use GPS it's
going to still be there next week next
year 10 years from now the second thing
that happened uh by another President
Bill Clinton he ordered the deliberate
errors in the system turned off
up to that point in time he did this in
uh 2000 up to that point in time the Air
Force had deliberately wiggled the
signal a little so your errors would be
up to 100
meters unfortunately what they didn't
recognize I tried patiently to explain
this to them but they weren't listening
is if I put a reference receiver listen
to The Wiggles broadcast them back to
the
user the problem is solved not only the
the original problem but you also take
out all the natural errors and you get
accuracies down on the order of a few
meters so at any rate Bill Clinton uh
and his administration recognized I I
should tell you one little Side Story I
was briefing the fourstar general in
charge of us space command and I
patiently explained this and he got it
fell by the name of Myers nice guy
bright guy he says well I agree with you
but I don't know that I can turn it off
and finally what happened is we needed
Bill Clinton to make the decision so the
president had to decide that indeed this
was a feudal thing to do but the point
is now that gave the civilians an
assured capability and fairly assured
accuracy and that's a good segue into
this chart a little busy but let me talk
you through it because it explains a lot
of the applications that we now
enjoy uh there are two rows here the
horizontal errors and the vertical
errors I will just tell you vertical
typically is about twice the horizontal
error and that's just driven by the
geometry so I'm just going to talk four
classes of users a general user
typically experiences raw GPS 2 and 1 12
to 10 m that's at the 95th percentile
that means only one in 20 is going to be
worse than errors like that for Aviation
we have a system called was which was
kind of invented here at Stanford perena
and some of uh his colleagues and
students helped FAA actually field that
system and that gives you an assured 2
and2 meters but more importantly it
tells you if the system isn't working
right and if you think about Landing an
airplane you'd like to know
that so uh the next category of Errors
is something or category of capability
is something we call realtime kenoma
this is a technique that is local
differential and gives you accuracies
down on the order of an inch in three
dimensions pretty good stuff but then we
have survey class receivers that give
you accuracy submillimeter sub the width
of a pencil lead in three dimensions and
I'm going to show you what the
implications are are of something like
that now how many on Saturday mornings
have heard a a couple of MIT Engineers
called Click and Clack you ever heard
them yep so they always have a Puzzler
so I thought I'd give you a
Puzzler okay uh and uh The Puzzler I'd
like to give you is why would anyone
want to track sheep with
GPS and just as Click and Clack do we
kind of let that simmer around as I talk
about everything else and then
eventually I'll come back to
it okay uh so let's turn to GPS for
Humanity and uh I don't have a prayer of
telling you all the applications so I'm
going to sample things I find kind of
fun and hopefully you'll find them fun
too the uh first and I'm just going to
give you the categories right now here's
the 10 major categories and you're sense
you will sense there's some overlap
they're not as pure as one might like
but certainly Aviation Emergency
Services
timing
agriculture
rescue recreational and
Automotive tracking
scientific military of course and
Robotics and machine control so what I'm
going to do is sort of sample one or two
out of each of these areas and that's
the heart of my my remarks
today so the first one is one of those
three surprises I said I was going to
talk about back in 74 we knew we could
do aircraft navigation no question about
it the surprise in 1992 is we did hands
off to touchdown down and that was a
group of my students led by a gent named
Clark
Cohen here are 110 straight traces of a
landing profile and if you can you see
the little okay there are 110 traces
count them this is one meter and this is
comparison to a laser tracker whose
presumed accuracy are these two
lines with the implication that what we
were track what we were doing is far far
better than a meter we have reason to
believe what we were doing is somewhere
on the order of a few inches in three
dimensions and it turns out if you have
a few inches in knowledge of where the
airplane is and a knowledge of what the
desired flight path is you can do 110 if
you have a band of really bright
graduate
students and uh I'd like to acknowledge
some of those uh Stu cob I think I saw
Dave Lawrence here somewhere now there
he is uh Stu cob Dave Lawrence Boris
pervan Clark Cohen and I've left some of
them out and candidly they did all the
work but it points out one other thing
they weren't all my
students one of the real Hallmarks of
Stanford is you don't have to be in a
given Department to work on something
you can kind of put all the students
together in a real team environment they
work on a PhD they go back to their
Department they're all part of Stanford
engineering and I think it's a strength
that Stanford has probably probably
better than any other school that I know
so that was a pretty good surprise but
there's a lot of other things that GPS
can do for Aviation and this is a
partial list and I'm not going to work
through all of them but I'd like to pick
out something we call Pathway in the
sky pathway in the sky is the idea that
you would have a head-up display in an
airplane that when you're trying to fly
an instrument approach is intuitive
rather than a rather than a bunch of uh
a bunch of
needles and so what we're trying to do
here is show the airplane's future
position and tell it you're going to fly
through these
pentagons it turns out a pilot can do
that one heck of a lot better than he
can fly needles and as a matter of fact
the pathway which is
calculated is an intuitive projection of
three dimensions rather than simply some
needles
it's especially suited for curving or
dog-legged approaches and in fact Juno
Alaska has an ex example that is very
noteworthy there's some mountains in the
way and you can't get an electron beam
to steer you around those mountains and
as a result when the fog comes in under
normal conditions it's shut down it was
one of the first places that we went to
actually show how well this would work
and I have to give great credit to Dr Dr
Andy barrows who ran that and again the
way we work at Stanford Dave Powell was
his advisor and this data shows why
that's so good here uh this is airs you
probably are having trouble reading this
but that is 0 to 100 ft these are the
conventional techniques that are used in
landing an airplane and this is the raw
instruments and here's some aiding and
what you can see is even with the best
aiding and a skilled pilot it's still a
50 to 60 or 70 foot error that is
characteristic of Landing an airplane
here is Andy Barrow's system the pathway
in the sky and it turns out you don't
need as much training so it shows that
the errors are now down around 20
ft it helps in an enormous number of
ways if I can get the right chart it
helps in terms of safety it helps in
terms of the intuitive learning of how
to fly instrument approaches and Andy wa
later went off and formed his own
company very successfully and then as
all small companies do he got bought
up next example is something called
tailored arrivals and this was given to
me by the chief pilot of United they are
actually flowing uh they're actually
flying these uh experimentally this
shows the approach in
of a 747 coming out of Honolulu and
going into San Francisco some of you may
recognize that when you get to that
point you're lined up right at the end
of the
runway what's unique is that instead of
having a series of descents and altitude
holds where you reapply the power and
come down in stair steps you instead do
it as a Continuum it's a four a true
four-dimensional approach all the way
down to to the ground and it is part of
what the Next Generation air traffic
control is going to be it's just one
small aspect enabled by GPS of course so
you're not only flying this in three
dimensions you're really flying it in
four and by that I mean at each point
there is a prescribed time for you to be
there so fitting your piece of macaroni
with the next guy's piece of macaroni
then becomes a very predictable
process so um what are the payoffs
better safety less delays more Airways
capacity uh smaller Fuel and carbon
footprint now this comes to the
astonishing part at least to me the
average fuel saved per Landing by a 747
is600
lb close to a ton there are I looked it
up there are over 28,000 commercial
flights in the US per day now all of
them aren't 747s and all of them aren't
on this flight path but you can multiply
those two numbers together and get some
feeling that whatever the number is it's
huge let me turn to another area this is
emergency services Emergency Services
involved
150,000 GPS units
today the
uh those users use GPS to pinpoint Point
their location if you have a cell phone
GPS is the fundamental way that they
know where you are if you have a problem
with 911 and that allows them to Vector
the police ambulance whatever to that
location but there there's a another
part that's equally important and that
is the part of allowing the dispatcher
to precisely track your progress and
tell you when there's going to be
someone there or recognize if the
ambulance or fire truck is not going to
make
it next general area is timing and
frequency uh a lot of applications of
timing and frequency almost all cell
phone towers Trace their origins of time
back to GPS banking is used for
transactional verification but I'd like
to talk this time about coordinated
International
time there's a saying a man with a watch
knows what time it is a man with two
watches is never
sure if that's true the Naval
Observatory has a big
problem they have 44 atomic clocks the
greatest Ensemble of timekeeping of
precision timekeeping apparatus in the
world I believe uh CMS masers uh Etc and
the point is they use this to keep time
coordinated between the United States
and Europe and everything else GPS is
the key that's how it all ties together
and the idea is simply that the users on
either side of the Atlantic look at the
the same satellite know where they are
and infer where they are in time in the
fourth dimension uh in the old days they
used to actually package a CCM clock and
fly it across the Atlantic to do this
clearly this is a lot
quicker the specified time capability
according to the GPS spec is 100
nanoseconds that's 100 billions of a
second truth be known we do considerably
better than 10 and in many cases down to
approaching one nond according to the
timekeepers very interesting application
indeed here's another surprise at least
it was at the time not a surprise now
perhaps expected in 1974 we could do
Land Navigation in
1996 again thanks to some students this
Mike O Conor and uh Tom Bell we
demonstrated automatic steering to an
inch as well as three AIS attitude
control to about a degree and the reason
you see these antennas on the roof is
they're using differential GPS to
determine what the orientation is of the
tractor now why would you want to know
that the reason is if you're doing
really precise work it isn't where the
antenna on the roof is somewhere behind
this humongous tire is a toe bar you
want to know where the toe bar is and so
you have to correct for the distance
from here to here sometimes called the
lever arm arm correction John Deere was
kind enough to send me 3/4 of a million
dollars in two of these huge tractors
and uh I was lucky enough to have a
bunch of terrific students who are able
to put this together and I should
comment this is the typical accuracies
here you can't quite read them but I'll
tell you on a rough field 5 MERS per
second and said you don't want to un
unless you have no respect for your
kidneys whatsoever you do not want to go
on a rough field at 5 meters per second
but the worst eror on the order of 3
in and this is now over an 800 million
doll a year market and you say wow why
would that happen well here are all the
applications of GPS for farming and the
one I'd like to just touch on is crop
spraying that's herbicides fertilizers
or
pesticides this chart shows well this
chart doesn't show it there are over $18
billion a year currently spent on
nitrogen 30 to 50% of the costs of
producing corn or wheat is in the
nitrogen nitrogen's use as a matter of
fact now here comes a chart uh here's
world population in brown and here is
nitrogen use in red and it shows the
nitrogen use is far outpacing the growth
in world population why is that
important well well this shows one
example of why it's important this is
fertilizer runoff damaging the
environment because of oxygen depletion
in the area just outside New Orleans
this is down in Mississippi River delta
it's killing fish polluting the water it
is a definite problem can GPS
help you incidentally that's one of the
grand challenges for engineering that
the Nae is
sponsoring so without with with a
automattic steering it turns out the
overlap the 8 to 10% overlap you know
when you're fertilizing your lawn you
can't tell exactly where you were last
time so you come back and put in a
generous overlap farmer does the same
thing uh 8 to 10% reduction is potent is
potentially there plus if you have
automatic
steering you can run day and night and
incidentally in fog because if you go
over to the valley many times in the
wintertime when the air is calmest it is
foggiest and you can't even see where
that last row was so the results are
visible the
economic Advantage is compelling because
it's 8 to 10% of perhaps $18
billion 1.4 to $1.8 billion
potentially but wait there's
more as the television guy
says if you look at a field each of
these patches is a calibration of the
demand for nitrogen and for example in
the Blue Area the demand is 0 to 80
pounds of of nitrogen per uh acre the
red area is three or four times that and
the point is if you can sample this
which is what the industry is trying to
do you can modulate the amount of
fertilizer you use to correspond to the
little patch you're on and the 8 to 10%
you were talking about is probably will
be very small it's dwarfed when you
start to use this technique so again a
benefit hopefully for Humanity search
and rescue obviously there's lots of
search and rescue applications I'd like
to focus well and most of you are
familiar with OnStar uh if you crash
your OnStar equipped car they uh call
Emergency Services uh to wherever you
are and uh evidently that works
extremely well but what I'd like to talk
about is emergency beacons it goes by
this mouthful it's called an emergency
position indicating radio Beacon and I
so we'll just call them a beacon but you
activate it simply by throwing a switch
and it has a GPS coordinate and it
broadcasts on a certain frequency a
satellite picks it up tells the
appropriate authorities you have a big
problem here and those exact GPS
coordinates pinpoint where they should
go case in point back in n
2009 over 955 people were rescued off
this ferry boat down in the Philippines
that had run a ground apparently there
was some bad weather coming in but they
got them all off in almost all there's
10 of them that apparently were lost but
almost all of them were lost because
they used a system as I've just told you
about another category Recreation and
Automotive of course you're all familiar
with the female voice that comes on and
says if possible May a legal
U-turn well I'd like to talk about
geocaching which is uh quite a different
thing I some of you may have heard of
Geocaching it's a new recreational
activity uh people hide treasures at GPS
locations and uh in Little Boxes and uh
then you and your family or whoever go
out and usually you get the coordinates
from GPS you get close enough and then
you've got a another whole dimension of
of a problem because you got to locate
where the heck that little box is but
worldwide it's pretty popular over 5
million participants there's over a
million
geocaches so if you want to do this you
go on the web and look up
geocaching and uh bring your kids or
grandkids because they'll have a good
time with it I guarantee it tracking
there's lots of things we can track uh
I'd like to focus on one and that is uh
something you will find a little mundane
and that is concrete
trucks Oh by the way uh recently the
Supreme Court had a ruling that uh the
the police law enforcement people cannot
put bugs on cars without a warrant and I
personally think that was an excellent
decision it was nine to nothing and it
says if you're going to go track
somebody you better have some rationale
rather than tracking just anybody uh but
in the case of vehicle Fleet that you
own obviously you're entitled to track
it so the way it works the way it goes
down is this here's a concrete truck
filled with concrete and the
GPS location plus a lot of parameters
from the truck itself are all geotagged
back to a central location and then the
uh dispatcher or someone else can look
up on a website find out exactly where
that truck is the advantages
productivity I don't know if you know
much about concrete but once you mix the
rete up from that instant it's getting
weaker and weaker and the longer you
keep turning it the weaker it gets so if
you are a user of concrete you would
like to have a tag that tells you when
did they put it in that truck and when
did they dump it at my spot because
it'll tell you whether that concrete is
going to fail or
not but there's another thing that
happens we track driver compliance and
safety how fast were you going around
the
corners let me tell you you if you have
this it will spoil your whole day as a
concrete truck driver or as an owner
because you have five cubic yards of
concrete that is rapidly hardening
because it isn't rotating anymore I'm
certain you
understand so a little story one of
these drivers I guess he was stopping
off to see his girlfriend and he didn't
particularly like the dispatcher peeking
in on him like that so he decided he
would solve the problem and brought some
aluminum foil from home
and carefully covered up his
display I think his jobs in some
Jeopardy another application that's uh I
think interesting and I don't think
violates the the warrant problem is
tracking your own child and you can put
a GPS device on them and there's an app
that tells you exactly where that child
is as well as possibly communicating
with them my third surprise um back in
1974 we thought we could do surveying to
about a
meter and the surprise is because we can
do reconstruction of the carrier we can
do it to that millimeter and here's
where it pays off we can use it to
measure the motion of tectonic plates
almost
continuously this uh shows the
instabilities they're called the wand
instabilities and this is the one the
Fuca plate and this is the North
American Plate over here and these are
velocities measured by
GPS just to calibrate you the length of
that arrow is 1 inch per year and these
are measured in three
dimensions uh my take away from this
chart incidentally so see this long
green line here my takeaway is I'm glad
I don't live in Seattle because the wuka
plate is coming
however uh but we can also see the fine
grain motion of tectonic plates and this
shows a series of relatively slow
earthquakes this is horizontal
displacement and in Canada there's a
place where these events occur about
every six can you see my pointer up
there yeah okay um in Canada these
events occur about every 16 to 18
months and they reflect a continuous
motion but also a series of reliefs of
stress in other words at this point it
is almost predictable those motions
almost but we're not quite there yet and
to calibrate you there is one inch so no
hello there is one inch so what it is
doing is telling you uh to uh millimeter
accuracies the relative motion of
tectonic plates and when LMA PR went for
example I had a couple of geodetic
receivers and another one of my profess
one of my professor friends here says
can I borrow them put them on either
side of LMA pra well when it gave it was
this but it turned out for the next week
or so it kept creeping and that was a
motion that's very very hard to measure
any other
way uh so there's a lot of other ways in
which surveying is u a major application
of GPS I've shown some here damn
deformation and then there's a whole
series of things that relate to machine
control scientific lots of applications
GPS routinely measures the figure of the
earth it measures where the center of
the mass is it routinely has to know
where all the little lumps are or you
could not do that prediction 990,000
miles away but I'd like to look at
something entirely different I'd like to
look at migratory
tracking this is a blue fin tuna
arguably the the most magnificent fish
that has ever been on the face of the
Earth these things can go very very fast
you may not know it they're actually
warm-blooded they can actually increase
their internal temperature by 20° which
gives them a tremendous advantage over
the fish they're preying on but what's
the problem well the problem is that the
scientists have been pleading that we
need to stop fishing them we're killing
them and this is the chart that is the
evidence the uh the biomass has
apparently gone down to uh a small
fraction of the historic levels where
does GPS
fit the east and west side of the
Atlantic got in a big argument saying
we'll do ours you do yours these things
don't mix GPS pointed out that was not
true these show the actual path track of
tuna fish and it's clear East and West
is the same biopop polation and you
better manage them all together another
example GPS for Humanity here's a a
something being developed by HP it's
tests a fight it's a fight against
malaria and it's in bwana recognize that
by the boat swana flag
perhaps maybe
not uh but the point is the data is
collected in a very simple smartphone
app this nurse records cases of malaria
because what the doctors and the people
who are concerned
about outbreaks of malaria would like to
know is where's the where's the
concentration where should we focus our
activities to stop it and what this does
is feed a big database so that they can
pinpoint exactly where that con those
concentrations are developing and the
goal is of course to help wipe out uh
malaria and I think that's a a major
thing that uh has been taken on by this
country there's a lot of military
applications I'm not going to talk about
them uh it turns out the military funds
GPS um by and large but I'd like to just
talk about
rescue and this was an example from 1995
this is Captain Scott o Grady you may
have followed that in the paper back
then he was shot down and evaded capture
for six days and then was plucked out by
the uh activities of the marine and navy
Rescuers he attributed his success to
his faith in God courage of his marine
and navy
Rescuers and his GPS unit which he
referred to as his Guiding
Light nice
example uh the last major application
area I'm going to discuss just briefly
is that of Robotics and machine control
uh here's a bulldozer and you notice
it's got two if you look closely two
antennas there that measure
three-dimensional position and tell you
exactly where the bottom of that blade
is the point is that in so
doing you can have anyone driving the
tractor you go directly from your
digital map of what you want the
landscape to look
like in his cabin he sees green means
dig red means fill and that's all he
really has to know as a matter of fact
there is even on the market today an
automatic system that measures this and
a centimeter level accuracy
automatically positions that
Blade the savings no surveying is needed
fewer mistakes and quicker
competition now there's another GPS
application area that I did not
discuss and I'd like to just touch on
it that's this
[Music]
area and I have four examples from guess
where very bright
audience four examples from uh Stanford
this is the autonomous Model helicopter
that won a national competition uh done
by Bob Cannon and his students GPS was
used to measure 13 things position
velocity attitude attitude rate and time
count them 13 things and it was
controlled by GPS alone this is a
robotic GPS sailboat done by one of my
students he did all the work this is a
marvelous uh device he took an old
catamaran Hall he designed this air foil
that looks like a saale but it's really
an air foil and showed that he could go
out in San Francisco Bay and control
this within a meter in the face of
variable currents and variable winds
hands off real tur of force he's now
professor at uh Santa Cruz um this is
the Sanford robotic car I will say a few
more words about that in just a minute
it won one of the early DARPA challenges
but I shouldn't over exaggerate there's
a lot of good competitors out there
Carnegie melan and other universities
doing the same thing and the last is a
robotic
snowcat done by perena and his student
gorm oog now you will not be surprised
to learn gorm is a skier
matter of fact a very very good skier
and his PhD thesis involved controlling
that and he did it very well
indeed uh so I asked the question why
has GPS became a system for Humanity
it's effectively a worldwide utility
well the signals are free they're
guaranteed accuracies I've shown you
down to a millimeter availability close
to 100% worldwide and the receiver cost
its itself is dropped out of the picture
it's about
$3 for a really good receiver now that
isn't include the antenna and the
display and all that but the cost
Advantage is in the applications and the
goys the graphic user interfaces and
that's where the real payoff is for a
company or for the application and the
user because the applications generally
enhance safety improve productivity or
they're just convenient and fun now if
you think about it that availability
100% of the time has been taken for
granted and I think we should
acknowledge the Air Force and your tax
dollars continuing at work here are the
current developers Lieutenant General
Paul akowski down there in Los Angeles
and working directly on the GPS program
Colonel Bernie Gruber but that's the
development side there's also an
operational side that keeps those
satellites always broadcasting and
that's done by Lieutenant General Susan
Helms at the 14th Air Force at
vandenbberg and Lieutenant Colonel
Jennifer Grant at the second space
operations Squadron in Colorado Springs
and I cannot help but
mention Susan
Helms got her master's degree in Aro
asro from Stanford and she's also flown
on the space station four
times uh very very wonderful graduate
but on top of that structure is this man
and that's General Willie Shelton I have
great fondness for him he stands up for
all the users he regards himself as the
chief steward of GPS for the world and
so if you ever see him in the hall say
thank you okay uh now it's time for the
big GIS question back to The Puzzler I
posed earlier and it turns out what
these sheep were doing was trying to
trace the Chernobyl radioactivity path
and Professor David last of the
University of Wales was trying to see if
the radioactivity was somehow getting
into the grass and hence into the sheep
and hence into people he found out there
wasn't any but at any rate uh it's good
Puzzler what's next well let me just
rapidly say a few things about what's
next right now you as civilians rely on
a single GPS
signal what's next is the next GPS
satellites four new signals at two new
frequencies for
civilians glonass the Russian system
four new signals at two new
frequencies Galileo the European system
four new
signals at two new frequencies and the
Chinese
compass and the Japanese
[Music]
system wow
is my time
up okay and and the Japanese have a
regional system the point is all those
signals we don't have today they all
represent things that are a true
opportunity and I'd like to just mention
one that is Fond I'm uh that I'm very
fond
of the toughest the biggest problem with
a car is there's a human behind the
wheel you know that's where most of the
problems are they're not failed brakes
and stuff like that and as a matter of
fact in the last 10 years over 300,000
people have died on our highways and not
to denigrate the soldiers but 213 people
have died on highways for every soldier
that died in Afghanistan during the same
period the point is this is an enormous
opportunity and can all those gnss
signals do something for us in that
regard I think it can and I call that
brilliant Autos we can Implement A
system that uses not just GPS but
GPS miniature electromechanical systems
Radars Cooperative tracking with other
cars I'll tell you where I am if you
tell me where you are so you know in a
fog if someone has stopped right in
front of you or you can anticipate if
the road friction is not good enough all
those things are possible and you say
well that's not very new it isn't we
have driverless cars already this shows
Junior from Stanford and Odin from
Virginia Tech and they went on a course
on an deactivated Air Force Base George
Air Force Base and they had to follow
the rules of the road and everything
like that it was a DARPA challenge um so
that's a start and then we have this
Sebastian thr director of was was the
director of the Stanford artificial
intelligent laboratory has been
instrumental in the Google driverless
car application and how about this those
cars are being driven without a human at
the wheel that is an autopilot Convoy
and if you look very carefully you'll
see that there are two hands of each of
those drivers stuck out the
window you caught the don't drive this
at home right don't try it at home so
driver list and automatic cars I think
uh are something that's coming you see
degrees of it in Mercedes and some of
the other cars already electronic
stability control lasers and Radars all
helping you see how fast you're
approaching another car camerab based
Lane keeping all of those to me that
represents a real future opportunity
both in terms of PhD dissertations but
also in terms of a real
market so
all the good news what's the bad news
the number one worldwide issue in my
opinion is Spectrum
interference and it could come in a lot
of forms I'm going to highlight just two
of them
briefly this is a GPS
Jammer you can buy it on the web for
about 33
bucks it is illegal to use it turns out
one of these was operating in a truck
right near Newark Airport and I think
operated for two
months and they knew it was out there
somewhere and it kept driving by and
shutting down one of the monitor
stations for the wide area augmentation
system and when they finally found it
they prosecuted him to the fullest
extent of the law they took his the
vice now in Australia if you were to do
that you facing jail time in $100,000
fine and I frankly think we have to get
our act together in that regard here's
the uh here's the part of the license
Jammer and this shows the GPS signals
and these are frequencies and it says
GPS receivers can tolerate any signal
whose power is below this blue
line and the situation before the
proposed licensing of a certain
company was just a communication system
from satellites 40 Watts at 22,000 MI
about the same power level as GPS not a
problem in an adjacent we can tolerate
that quite easily then the FCC and their
great wisdom can I say
that that wasn't factious was it okay so
the light the SEC proposed licensing a
company that would broadcast powerful
signals from the
ground and those signal levels look like
this uh and I can't even draw it it's a
billion times greater than
GPS billion times that's a teaspoon of
water once a second compared to Niagara
Falls that's a billion
times and uh you can see what the
problems are it will trespass into GPS
but more importantly a GPS receiver and
we tested them to find this out can
reach out and kind of listens into the
adjacent band and fortunately I think
this has been shut down
and we don't have to deal with it again
uh hopefully we'll
see uh now one little piece of
philosophy here uh I've been asked many
times what was the driving philosophy
behind the GPS program in those early
perilous times and frankly I didn't
answer the question very well but about
three months ago I stumbled on something
that I thought really really distilled
what we were all about
and um it was chiseled in Granite on a
Sund dial I'm not making this up outside
the LA train station and there are three
phrases on this Granite the first phrase
is Vision to see so if I think back to
those times I think everyone that worked
for and with me had the vision of what
this could be the second line is the
faith to believe you have to believe you
can really pull it off in spite of just
seeing some Airy thing and the third
line is the courage to do and I tell you
there are a lot of people that I stand
in awe of who work for and with me that
put in long hours jeopardized families
they did a lot of things to make GPS
happen and we all owe them a great debt
I'm enthusiastic about what we have done
but a little in awe of some of the
prices we had to pay but having said
that it turns out probably every one of
your Heroes would say yeah that's what
we did so it's the foundation of many
engineering achievements and kind of
distills the whole
deal I can't finish without
acknowledging the wonderful help of my
delightful wife
Jenny and all my children and
grandchildren their enthusiastic support
has been essential so on behalf of of
all of us who had that Faith to believe
39 years ago thank you GPS success is a
tribute to the whole team of the
developers the innovators Stanford and
elsewhere
manufacturers supporters and let's not
forget also to you the
users thank
you
now comes the PHD orals is that
it I already got my degree yeah I think
we're going to stipulate a
pass uh folks uh we have questions both
coming in on Google moderator from the
remote viewers but also we welcome yours
uh would you like yes sir please hi
Winston copen thank you very much for
your words question for you since our
military depends so heavily on GPS what
do you recommend we do to preclude our
enemies from denying us access to
GPS uh you said it in an interesting way
um that is one aspect of the problem and
it turns out um many people have
agonized over the possibility that
somebody like that light squared thing
would jam our our system it turns out we
know ways for airplanes or trucks we
know ways to put directional antennas we
know ways to deeply integrate that
signal we know in the case of the
military that we can use two frequencies
rather than one so I don't want to
downplay that threat an equal threat is
that they use our system or their own
and frankly the only way we're going to
fix that is to jam it we're going to
have to jam them out in a military area
so I am not advocating and obviously you
have to do that very carefully you have
to avoid any impact on
civilians and I that is a dilemma we we
kind of let that one you know out of the
jar and it's there I can't think of
probably anything that has is a great
benefit to mankind humankind that
somehow doesn't have a downside and the
downside could be
that thanks Brad um why don't we
commutate between here and the remote uh
viewers uh the number one voted question
is if you had it to do again would there
be a technical feature of GPS you might
tweak or
change
um that's a good question and you have
to put it in the context of what we had
available then I mean you can't conjure
up something that doesn't or would not
have existed but I'll tell you something
that is probably not well
known when I first when we first built
that system there was a second civil
frequency and there was a little switch
in the satellite where you could send
out because we were power limited at
least as the uh solar panels aged and so
you could put that switch in the
civilian second frequency or the
military
the next generation of satellites did
not have that
capability the military realized they
were power limited and could not afford
to let the civilians have it and
furthermore they were still in the mind
process of dithering that signal and who
the heck needs ionospheric correction
which is what it's used for I let me
back up just a minute so
uh right now the military corrects the
ion there's a group delay because of all
these free electrons and it's an error
unless you calibrate it but it turns out
it goes as one over frequency squared so
if I measured at two frequencies there's
a little algebraic relationship and I
can sort out what the err is so you you
would like to have two frequencies so
now to answer the question I would have
ensured that there was a second civil
frequency on that's certainly one thing
I did and then there's a technical thing
that I would have done I would have gone
to a longer acquisition code for
civilians but I you you that's a little
esoteric but I I just think that would
have been better okay thanks there's a
and incidentally obviously now for the
newer generation satellites I would
Advocate the second and third
frequencies and the four additional
signals thanks Brad a question from the
floor yes I think you were first pick
the frequency for your
transmission how did we pick the lb
frequency we're at which is 157 5 it
turns out it's a a trade-off if you go
lower in frequency the effect of the
ionosphere is greater because it's one
over frequency squared a smaller number
makes a bigger error uh so the lower you
go in frequency is a problem on the
other hand if you go higher in frequency
the wavelength is shrinking and hence an
omnidirectional antenna is getting
smaller and smaller and it turns out L
band is about The Sweet Spot and that's
the reason a lot of people like L band
and that's the reason we get in these
elbowing match es with other people who
would like to steal our our
Spectrum dirty
guys Brad there's a corollary uh
question from Google which is gosh with
all these problems with interference why
don't we just increase the GPS Power by
a factor of 10 or 100 or
so uh I don't know if you know how
expensive it is to create power in space
you know it's not like you take your 60
three solar panels from your house and
just sort of stick them up there those
solar panels are very special they have
to
withstand um solar radiation
particularly the Van Allen Bel at our
our altitudes so the point is
doubling the power amounts to
doubling the solar arrays and pretty
soon that's a Fool's errand because I
can I can get a lot more uh resistance
to interference
by doing things to the user equipment
and Etc however having said all that the
military has a process or a plan of
possibly putting a big dish antenna and
in certain areas of the earth focusing
that power down a little more I I think
that's a very expensive idea and I I
would much rather see them instead going
to the kinds of things we know how to do
vector vector receivers which Jim
spilled ER has advocated for a long time
especially when we have you know 50 or
60 satellites on
orbit a question yes sir uh can you
maybe tell us about a time that was The
Darkest Hour of GPS maybe a time when
you thought man this is never going to
work and how did you get
out oh there was a dark
time dark time turned out I had never
taken a
vacation and and uh for various reasons
I went off for a
week and I had when I left I thought I
had this humongous
Reserve I thought I had a 10 or 20% and
and it was towards halfway through the
year and I had a 10 or 20% uh Reserve in
my budget and you know that's one of the
things you managed for it turned out
during the week three things hit me at
the same time the launch Vehicles
announced that the cost of a launch was
going to double the people that were
doing the user equipment said that their
equipment was going up and the control
segment had a terrible problem I came
back to discover that I didn't have a
surplus anymore I had a negative Surplus
that's called an
overrun and uh for the next three months
we fought like heck for survival because
the air force was going to take any
opportunity to shoot
me matter of fact got to tell you a
little story The Air Force really really
did didn't like this program and so I
was in my normal fashion going back to
Washington once every week or two and
talking to everyone tell them it's okay
I I tell them all the problems and we
fix those and here's the new problems
except I'm walking down the halls of the
Pentagon and all of a sudden I see this
Major General coming towards me and I
know who this guy is he's a West
pointer and I'm trying to sort of walk
around him and he maneuvers right and
suddenly he's he's about that far
away and his forefinger is protruding
from my chest like this and he's saying
Parkinson your otherwise brilliant
career is going to go down the tubes
unless you stop advocating this system
what do you suppose I
said yes
sir and totally ignored
[Laughter]
him
uh sir go ahead do the Air Force view it
now oh uh they're enthusiastic converts
but of course it took a couple of Wars
no I'm serious and the whole Armed
Forces as a matter of fact there's an
army colonel and maybe you read this in
that paper that I wrote but there was an
army colonel and I think it was second
Iraq uh War who was asked do you need
any space systems and he says no I don't
need those darn any you know fill in the
Bry CU he used a bad word uh Space
Systems as long as I have my space
communication system and
GPS he didn't need
it I think he thought it was
magic Brad that gentleman right
there how did you decide on the physical
side of size of the satellites you use
for transmission that is an excellent
question I can tell you're going to be
an
engineer I'm not kidding this is my
pseudo grandson by the
way uh it turns out the way we launched
the satellites was on a refurbished
Atlas F an old intercontinental
ballistic missile that had been stood
down and it turned out that the size
that we used was as big as you could
launch
and it turned out that those uh
refurbished intercontinental ballistic
missiles were the cheapest way to get
into space so it was driven by cost and
capability in other words we couldn't
make it any bigger because we couldn't
launch it cheaply good
question
sorry sir when a satellite fails you
somehow just shoot it back down to get
out of
or no you sure
don't uh as any um he uh you're not an
astrom major sir so I I I will tell you
it takes almost as much energy to get it
down as it does to get it up so it's a
lot cheaper to throw it out somewhere
and so what they do is they preserve a a
certain amount of
propellant and boost it up to a higher
altitude which unfortunately you can
think of as a junkyard I don't like that
but it's the only thing we have today uh
ideally what you'd do is kick it out and
an orbit around the Sun but nobody does
that
oh go
ahead speaking of the Sun what are your
plans about triple solar flares to
deflect them and as I can see your bent
to saving energy are you going to
capture
them um well the immediate problem of
solar flares for GPS is pro is very
unlikely it would would actually harm
the satellite but what it does is pump
the
ionosphere and it it puts so many
active um ions in there that the it
tends rather than simply delaying to
make the osphere look opaque to the
radio waves and frankly so far at least
in the United States in the temperate
zones we've not had a big problem with
that but something to be concerned about
and it's something as a matter of fact
our friends at the FAA when they're
talking Landing systems have to take
into account and a lot of the research
that goes on under per is aimed at the
Integrity problem aimed at ensuring if
GPS gives you an answer it's right and
it's one part in how many times 10 to
the 7th 10 to the 7th one only one time
in 10 million times can that GPS lie to
you and that's the uh that's the
standard I'm glad it is but it sure gave
us fits for a while we tried to get the
was system in so we fair and others
tried to get this uh FAA system working
and we had millions of data points that
showed it worked great and they said you
haven't even begun to prove it but we
merged two years later
bloody bowed but we finally succeeded in
doing it the point point is the FAA
insisted that it meet those high high
standards now so what's the consequence
the consequence is if it doesn't think
you possibly one time in 10 million have
the right answer you don't get any
answer and so Mr pilot don't depend on
this and frankly that's the right way to
look at
it yeah that was that was good fun the
the the tricky part was that they wanted
the the 10 to the seven points during
the io storm that we talk about
right
please all was there any aspect of this
that could be attributed to dumb luck as
opposed to hard
science if you're talking did everyone
hear the
question is there any aspect of this
that could be attributed to dumb luck
rather than
science well I I got to tell you I'm a
lucky
guy in terms of having run it and I I
probably had the right background the
right guy Etc but you still look back on
life and you see all Robert Frost Little
Forks in the road that somehow you did
this that and the other thing so in
terms of what happened in terms
of in terms of being able to get some
key officers for example maybe that was
dumb luck in terms of the
design there wasn't much dumb luck in
there we uh I don't think so anyway well
it stood the test of time um
and I uh I if there's another dimension
of that
answer I I'll let it go with that good
question for the nation I think there
was a colonel who took the job that was
you yeah he you know that story right no
they don't please so I am I am I'm like
a kid in a candy store not on GPS I'm I
am the the chief engineer for a program
called aze the advanced ballistic
re-entry system SPO and I am designing
maneuvering re-entry vehicles and the
controls problems oh wonderful complex
control problem and I've been doing this
for a while and the three star general
calls me into his office and I'd gotten
a hint about this and he said well we'd
like to oh and and I on this program I
was I was a colonel but I was working
for a two-star general and he said Brad
spend the money any way you
want you know $100 million a year it's
quite a bit so this uh the three- star
general in charge of the whole operation
called me into his office and here's the
dumb luck part maybe and he said uh I'd
like you to go over and run
this floundering program uh on
navigation
satellites and I said I uh
and you know get get this I three star
general sort of a god-like figure and
I'm sitting there looking him in the eye
and he said uh yeah I'd like you to go
down there what do you think of that and
I said well General if you do that am I
going to be the program
director he looks at me and he says no I
can't promise that and I said in that
case I'm not a volunteer and he didn't
expect that answer at
all because I got about 15 ft outside
his office and he transferred me anyway
is that the story you were okay he's
heard it
before any uh yes sir I've been flying
with GPS probably for 20 years or so and
I just listen to your attended attend of
the sth errors but I can tell you you
know
98% of the time it's r on and 2% of the
time it says I'm three miles over this
way or five miles over that way and I
carried two different GPS receivers with
me and uh does that sound like something
you've encountered uh it sounds like you
don't have an FAA certified
receiver well that's
well no it makes a big difference all
receivers are not created equal and I'm
certain you have a nice receiver but
getting to the point of certification is
a hard problem and I again I wouldn't
know what what the problem would be and
I wouldn't want to defend the GPS is
always right but if you're listening do
12 or 13 satellites which you can when
you're in the air there should be enough
crosschecking that if something is going
wrong you should know it we call that R
receiver autonomous Integrity monitoring
could be the algorithm inside the GPS
receiver it could it could it could sir
from the Auto industry they would have
blamed the mapping software not
the so quick question U Can you estimate
how much the public GPS system costs the
government per year to run and I'm not
an NBA student by the way how much the
public GPS
system um you can't it's all one
system so you can't actually separate it
but I I think I know where your question
is going I think the budget for
GPS is close to a billion dollars a year
it's a lot of money but you see it's the
enabler for every Precision weapon
system in all three services
it is the basis for NextGen the air
faa's air traffic control system and by
the way when people have studied this
they've come to an interesting
conclusion that the taxes paid by the
industries that are supported by GPS
more than pay for the system now that
doesn't present uh prevent um
politicians from trying to add taxes
because you know the politicians want to
take the money in and then Dole it out
to their friends
stuff Brad our minders have suggested
that we take no more than one more
question is there one more question on
the floor
yeah I saw that hand first satellites
last and are you limited by radiation
damage in the solar cells or the
electronics just becomes Obsolete and
you just want to get rid of it that is a
great question the uh it turns out the
average on lifetime average lifetime on
orbit right now is somewhere around 11
years but that doesn't say that that's
what's going to happen we have at least
I think three or four satellites over 20
years old we have trip redundant clocks
we have dual redundant Power Systems on
the output we have an extra uh Gyro in
terms of attitude they're at the Apes of
a regular
tetrahedron so it turns out the answer
to your question is usually the solar
panels slowly degrade
and frequently the clocks you start to
use the backup clocks and pretty soon
you don't have enough uh if it's done
right it's like the one horse Shay you
remember the poem about the one hor Shay
it fell apart it went like crazy and
then all of a sudden everything went
wrong and that is the ultimate in
designing a satellite you see because
then you have not added too much
reliability on
anything okay bra um I certain
I thank you thanks thank you p uh we
have a reception planned uh there should
be food and drink outside we're welcom
you all to stay uh for a while at least
and I think Brad will be around for a
little while longer for additional
questions so let me just thank you one
more time and uh just tell you that you
are our hero so thank you
wow